where do you go to ask Google cloud
platform questions how do you share best
practices and how can you learn from
others how do you stay up with a pace of
GCP in this video we'll walk through
some prominent resources and also
through some less obvious ones that may
work well for you in your GCP journey
[Music]
having the right resources of
information and using the right
communication channels can be the
difference between a regular and a
highly productive GCP user the good news
is you've found this video so you're
already on the right path it all starts
with the Google cloud homepage at cloud
Google comm this page remains a
reference for product descriptions and
documentation since many developers
identify themselves by the language of
their choice
we have landing pages for the most
popular languages supported by GCP such
as Go Python Java nodejs php.net Ruby
and Kotlin let's that go as an example
the landing page for go will walk you
through how to deploy your web apps
using App Engine and how to use GCPs
idiomatic go api's and libraries if you
look at the Kotlin you'll find quick
starts for compute engine cuban a DS
engine and App Engine as well as code
labs and tutorials to build auto scaling
backends from mobile apps and
instructions for using your favorite
Java and coughlin frameworks blog posts
are great resources for both new and
seasoned users to stay on top of GCP the
main google cloud dog at cloud
google.com slash blog typically has
multiple posts a day and covers products
features and also partner and customer
stories you are probably also interested
in content that is not exclusively
written by Google the GCP medium
publication is a list of articles
curated by practitioners for
practitioners if you'd like to share
your experience with the community this
is a great place to be noticed this
publication also features a weekly recap
of the GCP news in the last week and
believe me there's no such thing as a
quiet week if you're into podcasts maybe
you have a commute or some other time to
listen to technical audio content then
you should subscribe to at least one of
these two weekly podcasts the GCP
podcast and the kubernetes podcast both
of them feature news of the week and
interviews with Google engineers as well
as
partners customers and community members
since you're watching this you may be
interested in more video content from
the GCP youtube channel we have videos
published here on a regular basis and
most of them are grouped into playlists
around topics products and events there
are other several related YouTube
channels such as firebase tensorflow
Google developers G sweet or Apogee if
you're hanging out on Twitter
you should definitely follow Google
cloud platform at GCP cloud and consider
also following one of these active
accounts firebase G suite developers
Google Maps platform Google open source
and again a PG several GCP members
monitor these handles to engage with the
community and it can be a great way to
get the team's attention of course this
is not a replacement to our support
options while we're on the topic of
social media we also have spaces on
Facebook as well as on LinkedIn check
those out the GCP community is large
vibrant and growing quickly it exists
online and in a variety of real-world
places and this community landing page
covers both community tutorials our
community contributed how to's with an
open publishing process hosted on github
there are close to 200 tutorials to date
and if you cannot find what you're
looking for you should request it or
maybe even write something yourself and
submit it on the real world side user
groups and GCP meetups are great places
where like-minded people meet to share
their experiences their best practices
and maybe even to find a job they're
active meetup groups around the world
and there should be one nearby
if not then create one it's easy and the
personal rewards are numerous you can
also attend conferences small medium or
large ones such as the one organized by
Google Google Cloud nexts or our summits
or on board events and dozens of CDs
around the world you will also find GCP
content in many industry events such as
ask on cube con dev ox in Europe
and of course in the more than 600
community LED deaf fest events in all
these events you will be able to learn
from technical sessions meet with cloud
engineers and ask questions getting help
from peers can turn out to be a big
asset and some of it can come in the
form of answers on Stack Overflow but
did you know that Google engineers
maintain and monitor a number of GCP
related tags this is part of GCP
community support and details are
documented in the page mentioned in the
description below of course there is
always formal support and if you're
starting out with GCP then I would
suggest that you purchase silver level
support using a portion of your $300
trial credit right from the console and
the support section here's a quick tip
with a picture being worth a thousand
words imagine the value to your
colleagues of a visual representation of
your GCP architecture made with
great-looking icons and diagrams from
cloud google.com slash icons this
resource contains vector graphics PNG s
slides and templates for popular tools
such as lucid chart and droid I oh and
last but not least I couldn't leave you
without a cheat sheet the Google Cloud
for words or lies cheat sheet the sheet
comes in many different formats
including several print friendly formats
and it is maintained on github
it's a very popular resource and you
should definitely check it out as you
can see there are many options for you
to consider pick the ones that work best
for you and share anything that you'll
find missing in the comments if you
liked this video please like subscribe
comment share and look forward to more
GCP essentials videos
[Music]